lay ball but wait for it first okay this  five-year-old california little leaker  he's going viral with his walk-up dance  to the plate check this out this is ben  he's taking his sweet time to get up to  the plate  his mom posted the dance on tick-tock  and it last  had more than four million views  and counting all right the team out in  the field is like what is going on  so his mom says she's kind of on the  goofy side so she thinks maybe he got  some of the oh my god kills from her  but then when he gets up to bat  it's like a double the left field yeah  he smokes it in the left field yeah he  just  you gotta love that if you're gonna  dance the dance you gotta you walk the  walk hit the ball